supporters of outgoing u.s president
donald trump have attempted to storm the
capitol buildings to support his
latest effort to overturn his election
defeat they're calling for president
trump to remain in office
citing unsubstantiated claims of
widespread election
fraud a protest became increasingly
violent as crowds
breached a barricade and scaled the
steps of the capitol building
some protesters entered the building and
clashed with police
congress is currently in the process of
certifying joe biden's presidential
victory
but several republican senators have
challenged the tally of electoral
college votes
president trump spoke at the rally
earlier and called on fellow republicans
to reject the presidential election
results claiming mike pence should
single-handedly
overturn joe biden's win
all vice president pence has to do is
send it back to the states
to recertify and we become
president and you are the happiest
people
all right let's go to uh washington
where we joined dw's uh
uh washington bureau of chief in this
poll uh welcoming us let's
start with this these disturbances then
um
we've heard that people are actually in
the capital or on the capitol steps and
there are clashes with police
fill us in right that's true and we hear
that they have weapons in their hands
and that there was
tear guard gas involved and that
people are leaving the building those
people who
really have to kind of execute uh their
duty today because after all this is the
day when the
senate and the house kind of agree on
who the next
president of the elect president of the
united states
will be so yes it's it's chaos
it's police all over the city the dc
mayor
just announced the curfew from 6 p.m
today until 6 a.m tomorrow morning so
this is
absolutely unprecedented the united
states
has never seen something like that
before
so let's just walk us through then the
sequence of events because this this
started
with a trump rally which was more or
less peaceful
right phil so people came together here
last night and there were some
minor clashes with police but nothing
big and then they
gathered uh very early this morning i
was down there
until actually a couple of uh yeah until
30 minutes ago people were really
peaceful i talked to them they came here
to protest the electoral outcome
they said it's rick but it was in a very
peaceful
manner most of the people i mean you saw
some
uh proud boys some kind of
militias who were a little bit more
aggressive
uh in the town and they kind of
gathered together but the majority was
very very peaceful and calm
until president donald trump came on he
delivered a speech
repeating the claim falls of the the
false claims that the
election were stolen then he called
those senators who were just about to
object the outcome of the electoral
vote by name so kind of to support them
and then and i think this is very very
important for this whole story
then he asked his supporters to march
into the direction of the senate and
that is what happened we saw like
thousands of people moving towards
the senate and then well we just hear
what happens then people
stormed uh some people stormed the
senate and it's it's it's
chaos now and uh we're looking at live
pictures as you talk so they
they're i don't know they're looking
like that a world a few could
quite certainly in the hundreds uh
possibly thousands of people there
and have they actually got into the
building and and because this was while
um the they were actually considering
the the
the the the votes from the electoral
colleges
exactly phil they just objected uh the
first vote
of the state of arizona they just wanted
to start
a two hours debate that's the procedure
uh then the two houses would have voted
on that
but with then kind of the the the masses
kind of stormed the house and a couple
of people
obviously got into the building
we hear that senators and taos
representatives
were hiding under tables the situation
is very unclear
i just heard some police officers
saying that they have to end the
situation before it's getting dark it's
probably another
two hours or so so that everything is
not
getting out of hand and again we have to
keep in mind today is a very very
important
day because they are coming together
uh to by the end of the the day decide
who the next president of the united
states will be and in this
very moment people storm the capital
of the united states supporters of the
current president of president
donald trump stormed the capital of
these united states
to stop this democratic procedure from
happening
so lawmakers had objected to the
electoral
um college vote there was a debate was
going on and
these uh people who have stormed the
building they have
stopped that debate from happening
because as
far as i understand it that session has
now ended
that is true phil that is what we hear
but the problem is if you want to say so
they have to continue to to vote today
because
this is a kind of the law this is what
the constitution says
on january 6 this year in 2021
they have to kind of decide who the next
president of the united states will be
there was no doubt that the majority of
both
the house and the senate by the end of
the day would vote
for would support i shall rather say
president-elect joe biden and in that
regard
just stick to to the constitution and
fulfill
their democratic duty but at this very
moment everything is interrupted
interrupted nobody knows what is going
to happen next
uh so it's a break they break they they
stopped everything
uh but i mean lawmakers say that's the
first thing the first reactions we get
here in the united states they have to
come together again
and kind of continue this procedure to
in
to make sure that the next president of
the united states
can be inaugurated on january 20th
so everybody now is waiting for donald
trump
to react he sent out a tweet saying
please
stay peaceful this is kind of allow me
to say that ridiculous if you see these
pictures because this is kind of the
opposite of being peaceful
uh what i hear from or what i actually
read um
that republicans kind of force him or
ask him please send out a plea
a tweet to to to kind of calm your
supporters down to stop them from trying
to get into the
the capital and and violate this whole
democratic process from happening
we don't know what is going to happen
police hopes that they can kind of
bring this together before it's getting
dark but again
it's it's it's unprecedented the united
states
has never seen something like that and
just
as you're as you're talking there we're
still looking at live pictures of uh
what's going on there in us and it does
look like uh
hundreds maybe in the the low thousands
of people
there i'm just watching the wires and i
see that the the us defense department
has denied the request
by washington d.c officials to deploy
their national guard
uh that's according to a washington post
reporter
on twitter and all this enos while
um vice president mike pence was in the
building
right uh and he just kind of fulfilled
his duty even so donald trump asked him
uh in front of these tens of thousands
of people gathering at the mall in front
of the white house
to not do that to stop the process
from joe biden becoming the next
president of the united states i have to
say joe
uh um mike pence vice president
vice president mike pence uh um
stood with the constitution uh he he
didn't get
kind of forced by uh by donald trump to
act in any way
anti-democratic but he is or he at least
was in the building i also hear that he
might
have been taken away because this is a
threat to him right
so we shall see but he has an official
role to play
in this whole procedure we are
witnessing uh
today okay i'm just looking at the wires
here i see that
republican uh senator mitt romney is
saying that uh donald trump has caused
this insurrection that's according to
the uh the new
new york times uh reporter on twitter
now
enos this is a process this this
certification
of of the electoral college votes
this process must happen but is there a
time limit
when does it have to happen by does it
have to happen tonight
well yes uh and everybody was expecting
it to be
a long process because um they can
kind of object uh the electoral vote and
then
they start or are able uh to have a two
hours debate and then the
then it moves on and nobody was
expecting it
to take longer than until midnight
so phil very frankly i don't know what
is going to happen
if they aren't finished by midnight it
looks like that this might
very well be happening i think at this
very moment hardly anybody has an answer
so
we will learn that over the next hours
i'm sure that
many many lawmakers are looking into
that right now it's a total
unprecedented situation right now so
we'll
we will follow it closely and
yeah we'll share all the informations we
are getting here from the united states
and i want to comment on
mitt romney's uh comments phil if i
might i mean have i have been down at
the mall for a couple of
hours uh today and again it was very
very peaceful
until until donald trump uh
delivered his speech and really pulling
uh
uh oil into the fire and
and heating or really kind of
getting his people ready to move towards
uh the capital and this is the outcome
of this
speech he delivered delivered this is
what
i think it's fair to say well it's fair
what what mitt romney said
he kind of started everything we are
witnessing
in this very moment you're watching dw
news and you're looking at live pictures
of what's going on at the u.s capitol at
the moment as you can see
uh it looks like uh people in the the
low in the hundreds maybe a couple of
thousand people have stormed
uh the us capital uh building at the uh
end
uh of a or during uh a session in which
uh a senate was uh uh in which congress
was looking at
certifying the results of uh november's
presidential election uh at uh
correspondent in washington uh
inus poll is whether she was out
amongst those protesters as donald trump
um talked to them a little earlier today
before
this happened enos
tell us about the police reaction
yeah i mean there was a lot of police uh
downtown
anyhow and the mayor of dc put out a
warning a couple of days ago
urging uh the the people of
washington not to go down
to the mall because obviously some
violence was expected but
and i mean i think the pictures we see
prove that obviously the police or the
law enforcement wasn't
really prepared for that to happened
there is a lot of like tanks and
everything coming now
moving now towards the capital
uh we see also policemen on horses
and everybody seems to to go there now
in uniform to calm down the situation
the the obviously the the the police
wasn't prepared
that people really really would try to
to storm the capital of the united
states
even so some violence was expected
i think it was really the words of
donald trump
who who made these people move so fast
there was a lot of
energy out there people had their
speakers moved to the capital moved to
the capital
the capital is ours don't give the
capital away
after donald trump delivered his speech
before that everything
was pretty calm and people just
exercised their right to demonstrate
okay uh we'll leave it there for now uh
anus uh ennis paul is uh
dw's washington bureau chief keeping an
eye on
things for us there more from her later
in the course of the program but for now
enis thank you
now so all this has gone on while joe
biden's democrats
have moved closer to taking control of
the senate
following two run-off elections in
georgia predictions show rafael warnock
winning his contest which would make him
the state's
first black senator and rising star john
ossoff has claimed victory after gaining
a narrow lead in his race
democrats need to win both seats to help
president-elect
biden advance his agenda in the senate
another no-biting election in the united
states
georgia is bracing for a political upset
in the traditionally red
state as democrats are poised to unseat
republicans
in twin runoff elections raphael
warnock's victory has already been
projected
if the result is confirmed he would
become the first black senator
to be elected from the state
so i come before you tonight as a man
who knows that the improbable journey
that led me to this place
in this historic moment in america
could only happen here we were told that
we couldn't win this election
but tonight we prove that
with hope hard work
and the people by our side anything
is possible but for his rival
senator kelly loffler anything is still
possible
we're going to make sure every vote is
counted every
that's right
every every legal vote will be counted
and i'm not going to stop working
the race will determine president-elect
biden's chances
of pushing his agenda through congress
let's talk to ahmed nuripur who's a
foreign policy spokesman
for the greens in germany's parliament
and a member of the bundestag
foreign affairs committee he's also
deputy chairman of the german u.s
parliamentary friendship
group welcome to dw sir can we start
with your reaction uh to this news that
the u.s senate has gone into emergency
recess
as these uh pro-trump supporters uh have
stormed the capitol building
these pictures are absolutely shocking
it's
absolutely that
people are incited to go to
today to the senate and then breach even
the floor of the senate
and to interrupt a constitutional formal
process of
the confirmation of a president-elect of
the country
uh i think the american democracy is
strong enough and the checks and
balances at the end of the day gonna
gonna work but what happened this this
evening
is a massive breach of political
cultural and democratic culture
of the united states and i hope that is
going to be a wake-up call for a lot of
people
who supported the insiders yet
to to wake up and hopefully they're
going to
find ways to break their polarization
which is leading to
this situation where do you believe this
incitement has come from
you know i saw that president the
current president
just just demanded for peaceful protest
but as we heard from from innis police
just just a few minutes ago
the people has been very peaceful when
they protested there
until donald trump delivered his speech
asking them to march today to today to
the hill and then to interrupt
what is happening and of course we're
talking about a constitutional
formal procedure and people coming from
outside just
can interrupt that with violence by
violence and this is what they did
and this is why i think this incitement
is uh definitely
um disgraceful and is obviously coming
from
the person who is the most
responsible one for keeping the
constitution in the united states
and that is who
this is the current president of the
country and this is this is
of course harming the democracy but i
hope it's gonna lead today
to a wake up call for for those people
in the gop
who uh played his polar race
polarization
uh game yet and now they come together
and find solutions for the country
in a very very uh crucial moment
so no doubt in your mind that donald
trump
caused this uh disorder
i don't know if he caused that because
you know at the end of the day those
people
who committed crimes by by attacking
armed forces of the country are doing it
by themselves and this is their
responsibility not to do so but having a
president of the country
just just denying any procedure which is
given by the constitution
is of course harmful and is one of the
factors leading to this situation
which is shocking which is of course not
only
by done by people who woke up in the
morning and decided to attack the
the hill but of course got some some
inside incitement by the current
president
just being told all the time that they
have to fight a fraud which
never has been um proven uh there never
had been
um evidences for of the
so-called stolen elections of the united
states of america
and this is underlining the trust of the
people
record numbers of people voted for
donald
trump in in november's elections
an even greater record number of people
of course voted for joe biden
but what does he say about the next
four years of american a political life
uh you know after the last election
elections i
traveled to um to west virginia to
mcdowell county
because this was the country with the
highest rate of the voters for donald
trump he got i think 994 percent of the
people in mcdowell county
voted for donald trump in 2016. i wanted
to understand
and what i saw there were a super crisis
of poverty and opioid
um and and people just were rid of
a system in in washington which is not
taking care for them
which is not even giving giving it a
they're giving some some attention to
their situation and donald trump
gave them the feeling that this has
changed and giving these people
not only a feeling of being seen but
also
solutions for this situation this is the
huge task
in the middle of a covert crisis this is
a huge task
of of of the next
administration in the united states and
i think
it's going to be output legitimacy which
has to be
brought up by by joe biden's
administration this is a huge
task and it in this kind of polarization
we are seeing which just as you just
mentioned has been manifested
by the election results we saw and we by
by the turnout
by the way we saw today in georgia also
just going back to uh the disorder uh
now
on the capital we've been just looking
at
um live pictures there what do you think
the police should do
about this i think
that this is the last thing that police
in in washington dc in this moment needs
are people from thousands of miles away
giving them advices
and i think the american democracy at
the end of the day is strong enough to
such a thing we had a very similar
situation to that
a couple of months ago in berlin also
having people who
tried to breach the german bundestag
strive to storm
and overcome the first life
of the police and
this was this where disgraceful pictures
we had there
um this is very similar to that what we
are seeing now in
in dc but at the end of the day our
democracies are strong enough
it depends of us as democ democrat and
i'm not talking about democrats as a
party but as
people who are uh democracy uh to
to calm down the situation to overcome
the polarization of in our societies
and to deliver so at the end of the day
the trust of the people
into our democratic system is is growing
again
so this these are the scenes that we're
looking at
now these are in the in the last few
weeks of donald trump's presidency
do you expect him to fade off quietly
into the distance once joe biden is
inaugurated in a couple of weeks
what we learned for the last four years
and unfortunately some kind of has been
getting used to is not not
to exclude something when it comes to
the current president
and also not expecting anything
being done quietly so of course
as a as a current president of the
united states
sitting in a most powerful chair in the
world he
still can do a lot of things um
i just can hope that this next two weeks
gonna
be uh more peaceful than today
in washington d.c by the way i
also hope that there won't be any
violence
after the speeches we saw today in
georgia this evening
so um no i just can't
exclude anything but uh two weeks
or um a timeline i think we can survive
together
all right so what's uh as we leave you
what is the biggest thing that you are
you are hoping for from
the next president
that he can deliver that he is not too
preoccupied by the domestic situation in
the united
involved in states politics and that the
united states of course especially the
two parties can come together
and deliver and and create and develop
solutions for for a country which is in
um
in which is faced with a lot of
challenges
the americans need solutions the
american people
like the germans also do not need
polarization and this is
what democratic parties republicans
democrats in the united states and also
the parties in germany has to understand
and not to work all right we thank you
for joining us
ahmed nuripur green member of the
bundeslags foreign affairs committee
you